[Applause]
emotions in tens of thousands of people
for under Barcelona streets following
the independence vote really excited I'm
filled I'm very happy I think I can
express my happiness
Friday's boat was carried out by secret
ballot in a Catalan parliament and
afterwards politicians saying
catalonia's anthem but separatists joy
may be short-lived as Spain's government
seizes control from the breakaway region
the regional police chief was fired and
Catalan President Carlos Bustamante will
no longer be paid and could face charges
of rebellion which carries up to 30
years in jail overnight there were some
small-scale scuffles as unionists and
separatists based off it's an
enforcement competition enforcement
competition lawyer and political
scientist Joseph Costas says it's a
matter of who can effectively govern
this land
it all comes to what authority people
are ready to obey voluntarily and if not
what kind of enforcement measures can be
put in place internationally the US and
European Union quickly sided with Spain
as more regions across Europe push for
greater autonomy here with protests and
civil disobedience plan the Catalan
police have called on its officers to
remain neutral Alex